on n'a plus du tout je dire à jean luc
mélenchon qui est qui et sur la retenue
on l'a vraiment à jean luc mélenchon qui
sort de ses bons et ça c'est vraiment
différent du premier tour
c'est une situation totalement inattendu
absolument inouïe la déroute du parti
présidentiel est totale et aucune
majorité ne se présentent
tous
mon message ce soir une fois de plus et
par des sages de combat aujourd'hui dans
son discours quand on analyse ce
discours de second tour qu'est ce qu'on
voit il un vocabulaire très fort c'est
ce qu'on va appeler le travail du champ
lexical pour historique des discours
sont habités par certains champs
lexicaux aujourd'hui c'est le champ
lexical de la guerre ce que vous
disposez d'un magnifique outil de combat
les défis les plus inouïes vont
s'accumuler devant vous pas un instant
nous ne renonçons à l'ambition d'être
seule clé gouverne ce pays c'est un
champ lexical guerrier et ça aussi c'est
tard c'est à calibrer avant de prendre
la parole votre public va se retrouver
dès facto dans le vocabulaire que vous
allez utiliser et aujourd'hui un public
qui attriste va être beaucoup plus
réceptif un champ lexical précis c'est
ça peut paraître logique mais c'est
difficile à travailler en pratique
souvent par contre effectivement un
public qui sort victorieux aura envie
d'entendre ce champ lexical combatif de
guerre c'est fondamental et et jean luc
mélenchon a très bien fait ce soir je
change de poste de combat mais mon
engagement et demeura jusqu'à mon
dernier souffle dans les premiers de vos
rangs si vous le voulez bien sur la
totalité des éléments présentés il ne
parle qu un seul moment de lui quant à
moi je change de poste de combat vous
aurez mon dernier souffle etc c'est la
seule phrase où il parle de lui donc ils
laissent vraiment la place dans ce
discours à l'opposition où il va
critiquer l'opposition c'est à dire le
parti perdant selon lui le parti qui
soutient la majorité présidentielle bon
débarras
d'avoir vu après monsieur blanc caire
éliminé dès le premier tour
voir éjecter les bornes york acheter mer
et l'injure yeuse nan shan à sept au
total et avant tout
l'échec électoral de la ma chronique
nous avons réussi
l'ojectif politique que nous étions
donné des opportunités incroyables vont
se présenter devant vous riez en
particulier devant vous la jeune
génération diète celle qui appelle avec
le plus de force à la rupture avec ce
monde et ses règles d'organisation
j'imagine qu'il veut se placer peut-être
comme celui qui aura réussi ce pari de
rassembler les jeunes et ça c'est à mon
avis un pari crucial pour jean luc
mélenchon maintenant que lui n'est plus
l'homme clé il peut donner ses consignes
oui le grand jaillissement de l'histoire
du plus profond de ce qu'est la france
des rébellions et des révolutions oui ce
grand jaillissement dorénavant un visage
le visage de notre collectif celui de
l'union populaire
ne doutez pas de vous même
ne cédez jamais à l'impatience
penser que chaque difficulté à deux
visages celui qui s'oppose à vous et
celui de l'opportunité qu'elle vous
propose le son il a donné des consignes
très claires c'est ce jaillissement il
avait parlé de déferlement après le
premier tour là il parle de
jaillissement après c'est une
terminologie très imagé on peut revenir
sur une notion qui est fondamentale et
qui différencie je pense jean luc
mélenchon des autres c'est certes sa
capacité à travailler en lice pour
imager mais c'est pourquoi il le fait à
jean luc mélenchon sait que ce n'est
jamais l'orateur qui détermine son
discours c'est toujours l'audience dans
l'histoire de la rhétorique nous avons
des typologies d'audience différentes et
c'est la typologie d'audience qui crée
le discours l'oratrice l'orateur doit se
confronter à l'audience avant de rédiger
un discours est là où il est très fort
je pense jean luc mélenchon sait qu'il
travaille beaucoup je pense qu'il
travaille beaucoup si les secours pour
qu'il soit digest non pas pour lui mais
pour son audience beaucoup de
politiciens devraient arrêter de dire ce
qu'ils ont envie de dire il devrait
continuer et commencer à dire ce que le
public désire entendre et ça c'est
fondamental la clarté au travers des
effets de méthodes métaphorisation on
l'a encore vu c'est très très clairs
discours post premier tour donc très
solennel il reste encore beaucoup de
travail par contre le 14 juin à toulouse
lors du rassemblement nuque et ce soir
lorsque nous enregistrons cette vidéo
juste après son discours du second tour
on le voit l'audience est différente et
donc le ton est différent le discours
est différent et à mon avis ce sont des
discours qui ont fait bouger les foules
jean luc mélenchon s'est adressé aux
électeurs il s'est adapté à la réalité
de son électorat